[Music]
The Wall Street Journal recently
reported on the so-called Bladerunner
curse in that 1982 sci-fi cult classic
starring Harrison Ford some real-world
corporations of 1982 appear prominently
in the dark neon-lit
cityscape of a fictional 2019 director
Ridley Scott's goal was to convey a
gloomy foreboding about the triumph of
corporate power in our not-too-distant
future
the curse is that many of the companies
in the movie such as Pan Am and Bell
Telephone no longer exist or were
gobbled up it's a curse allegedly
because this is supposedly unusual but
for all of their corporate power big
corporations are often powerless when it
comes to the simple task of surviving
only 67 of the firms in the fortune 500
and 1955 were still there by 2011 the
rest were lost like tears and rain the
lesson is that if you're worried about
corporate power don't be afraid of the
market but do be afraid of companies
joining with governments to artificially
extend their lifespan what do you think
about corporate power and our dystopian
future let us know in your comments also
let us know what other topics you'd like
our scholars to cover in 60 seconds and
be sure to subscribe for more research
and videos from the American Enterprise
Institute